whoo good stops to see where I was I was
probably about 5 to 10 minutes behind
him so he sort of turned around to see
where I was and turn back and at that
point he was turning back to peddle off
somebody grabbed him and I could see
from behind again it was unclear who
this person was
Hugo obviously were frightened and sort
of caught his arm away and then
proceeded to run couldn't go one way
because the canal was that side so he
went the other way
which was that sort of rose bushes they
went inside there and tried to escape
from this person what did you think was
your immediate thought when you felt
that person jump on you I felt really
shocked and I thought someone was trying
to hurt me so I just immediately ran
into the bushes to try and get away from
him and was it kind of panic yes been
scared right yeah and did you ever had
anything like this before happen to you
did you ever had that you know nothing
that that's ever happened to me before
and you ran into those bushes and what
happened um I ran into the bushes then I
kept running for as long as I could and
then I tripped over something like thick
on rose and vines and then I fell onto
my front and then the officer um at that
point I didn't know it was an officer
until he pulled out his taser he was
aiming that at me and he threatened to
shoot it shoot me if I moved I couldn't
see what was happening in there but I
went to go towards the bush to diffuse
the situation I was still saying stop
that's my son I haven't been shouted to
Hugo to stop as well because I could see
that the guy was behind him but Hugo
couldn't obviously see at that point
what was coming behind him he was just
trying to escape and just immediately as
I went to towards the bush another
officer came out of nowhere from the
side almost saw the angle behind me and
he started shouting at me and pulled out
a Taser and sort of was aiming it at me
and asking me to get down on the floor
and put my hands behind my back so then
I had to explain that I was obviously on
the charity bike ride much like who
as well and of trying to show them sort
of on my phone that app and where we
being etc I did ask them what the
description was of the people that they
were looking for cetera and they and
they told us that they were that they
they've had reports that they've been
establishing the area and my we fitted
the description at that point I did
think that you know that always being
profile to racially profile to be honest
I mean everyone's kind of speaks for
itself really in the way that they
approach the situation because I'm
pretty sure if you know I would been on
the bike ride as I usually am with my
family so my daughter normally comes
with me and my partner and do go it
wouldn't have happened like that or if
it was for example a white father and
son on the bike ride I'm pretty sure
that it wouldn't have taken that form
and afterwards it must have had quite an
effect on you yeah afterwards I'm really
worried about that going out on my own
if that happens again but this time
that's him if there's no adult with me
and and in the days afterwards did you
did you had to be about trusting people
and being we more aware of the police
yeah after you I've been more aware
although when we never I hear sirens or
see police go pass I'm like but I kind
of like worried a bit
well the Metropolitan Police have told
Sky News the Met has received a
complaint from a member of the public in
relation to this incident the Met takes
all complaints seriously and this will
be thoroughly investigated